[Music]
flag day in ukraine on the eve of
independence day but celebrations in
kiev are banned wednesday amid high
alert of a russian attack on a day that
also marks six months of war the second
city of harkev is on a 36 hour lockdown
following warnings from president
vladimir zelinsky the united states has
advised its citizens to leave ukraine as
soon as
possible zielinski said any russian
attack will receive a powerful response
talk of revenge in russia too at the
memorial for nationalist tv commentator
daria dugina ukraine denies russian
claims it was behind the car bomb that
killed her on saturday
her father far-right ideologue alexander
dugan says she died in the name of
russian truth and russian victory
at an international diplomatic
conference in kiev zielinski told world
leaders that his country's victory must
include taking back crimea annexed by
russia eight years ago we can't forget
that putin's invasion of ukraine really
started in 2014. we should have the
humility to acknowledge that not
everybody realized the sheer enormity of
what was happening at the time the west
may have regrets about crimea but it
can't afford regrets about zaparisia the
head of the international atomic energy
agency says he expects a mission to
finally be allowed to visit the
russian-controlled nuclear power plant
within days
both sides in the war blame the other
for the ongoing shelling being reported
there risking catastrophe at europe's
largest nuclear plant the city beside it
is named ener hodar energy's gift
of course we are worried how can it not
worry us says this man
it's like sitting on a powder keg
redmond shannon global news london